carlos cultiva tomates en dos campos
separados cuando los tomates están
listos para ser cosechados le interesa
saber si las alturas de las plantas
difieren entre los dos campos toma una
muestra aleatoria de plantas de cada
campo y mide sus alturas este es el
resumen de los resultados lo que quiero
que hagas es que pausa el vídeo y
realices una prueba te de dos muestras y
vamos a suponer que todas las
condiciones para la inferencia se
cumplen la condición de aleatoriedad la
condición de normalidad y la condición
de independencia
supongamos también que estamos
trabajando con un nivel de significancia
de 0.05 entonces pausa el vídeo y
realiza la prueba te de dos muestras
para verificar si hay evidencia de que
las alturas de las plantas difieren
entre los dos campos
muy bien ahora hagámoslo juntos como
siempre primero vamos a construir
nuestra hipótesis nula que dice que no
hay diferencia entre el promedio de las
alturas entonces tendremos que la media
de la altura del campo am es igual a la
media de la altura del campo ven ahora
que hay de nuestra hipótesis alternativa
bueno le interesa saber si las alturas
de las plantas difieren entre los dos
campos es decir no requiere saber si la
altura en el campo am es mayor que la
altura en el campo b o viceversa
entonces la hipótesis alternativa se
construye con base en lo que a él le
interesa es decir que la media del campo
am no va a ser igual a la media del
campo b es decir difieren
ahora para hacer esta prueba te de dos
muestras vamos a suponer la hipótesis
nula y recuerda estamos suponiendo que
se cumplen todas las condiciones para la
inferencia y ahora queremos calcular el
estadístico t con base en los datos que
tenemos de la muestra nuestro
estadístico t será igual a la diferencia
de las medias de nuestra muestra entre
la estimación de la desviación estándar
para la distribución muestral de la
diferencia de las medias esto es la raíz
cuadrada de la desviación estándar de la
muestra del campo am al cuadrado entre
el tamaño de la muestra del campo am más
la desviación estándar de la muestra del
campo b al cuadrado entre el tamaño de
la muestra del campo b ya tenemos todos
los valores para hacer este cálculo este
numerador es igual a
1.3 menos 1.6 todo esto entre la raíz
cuadrada de veamos la desviación
estándar de la muestra del campo am es
0.5 al elevarlo al cuadrado obtendremos
0.25 entre el tamaño de la muestra del
campo a que es 22 ya esto hay que
sumarle 0.3 al cuadrado que nos da 0.09
entre el tamaño de la muestra del campo
vemos que es 24 el numerador es
simplemente menos punto 3 entonces
tenemos menos punto 3 dividido entre la
raíz cuadrada de punto 25 entre 22 más
punto 0 9 entre 24
esto nos da aproximadamente menos 2.44
vamos a notarlo aproximadamente menos
2.44 y bueno si dibujamos una
distribución t y usaremos nuestra
calculadora para encontrar esta
probabilidad entonces aquí tendremos la
media supuesta de nuestra distribución t
y obtuvimos un resultado para nuestro
estadístico tm de menos 2.44 así que
estaremos justo aquí este es menos 2.44
entonces queremos saber para esta
distribución t
cuál es la probabilidad de obtener un
valor tan extremo como éste es decir
será esta área y también será esta área
que corresponde a 2.44 por arriba de la
media entonces lo que haremos es usar
nuestra calculadora para encontrar esta
probabilidad de aquí y después la
multiplicaremos por 2 para incluirla de
esta región
entonces la probabilidad de obtener un
valor tema
supongo que podríamos decir el valor
absoluto de t que sea mayor o igual que
2.44 será aproximadamente igual a am
e iremos a la segunda función luego a
distribución después a la función de
distribución acumulada t y cómo queremos
calcular la probabilidad de la cola que
tenemos aquí y después multiplicada por
dos
entonces el límite inferior será un
número negativo muy muy muy grande así
que podemos pensarlo como menos infinito
mientras que el límite superior es menos
2.44 y ahora cuántos grados de libertad
tenemos bueno si nos basamos en un
enfoque conservador será el tamaño de la
menor de las dos muestras menos uno
vemos que el menor tamaño de muestra es
22 entonces es 22 menos 1 lo cual es 21
ahora podemos pegar la función y
obtenemos este número de aquí y si lo
multiplicamos por 2 ya que este me da la
probabilidad de obtener algo menor que
esto pero también necesitamos la
probabilidad de obtener algo
o mayor a 2.44 por arriba de la media de
nuestra distribución t entonces esto x 2
será aproximadamente igual a cero punto
cero 24 vamos a notarlo 0.0 24 y a
continuación vemos que al compararlo con
nuestro nivel de significancia podemos
ver claramente que este de aquí que es
nuestro valor p en esta situación es
claramente menor que nuestro nivel de
significancia y por esta razón podemos
decir que al suponer cierta la hipótesis
nula obtuvimos una probabilidad muy
pequeña que está por debajo de nuestro
umbral entonces podemos rechazar nuestra
hipótesis nula lo que sugiere la
hipótesis alternativa que nos dice que
si hay una diferencia entre las alturas
de las plantas de tomate en los dos
campos